mais nous devons aller au-delà de
l'urgence et j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à
cette question
j'estime en conscience que nous devons
faire évoluer notre constitution pour
permettre aux pouvoirs publics d'agir
conformément à l'état de droit contre le
terrorisme de guerre aujourd'hui notre
texte comporte deux régimes particuliers
qui ne sont pas adaptés à la situation
que nous rencontrons premier régime
c'est le recours à l'article 16 de la
constitution
il implique que le fonctionnement
régulier des pouvoirs publics soit
interrompu le président de la république
prend alors les mesures exigées par les
circonstances
en dérogeant à la répartition des
compétences constitutionnelles et puis
il y à l'article 36 de la constitution
qui porte sur l'état de siège qui n'est
pas non plus approprié état de siège il
est décrété en cas de péril imminent
résultant d'une guerre étrangère ou
d'une insurrection à main armée dans ce
cas différentes compétences sont
transférées de l'autorité civile à
l'autorité militaire
chacun voit ici qu'aucun de ces deux
régimes n'est adapté à la situation que
nous rencontrons le fonctionnement
régulier des pouvoirs publics et nous le
prouvons aujourd'hui n'est pas
interrompue et il n'est pas concevable
de transférer à l'autorité militaire des
pouvoirs et pourtant nous sommes en
guerre mais cette guerre d'un autre type
face à l'adversaire nouveau appel un
régime constitutionnel permettant de
gérer l'état de crise c'est ce qu'avait
proposé en 2007 le comité présidé par
edouard balladur qui réfléchissaient sur
l'évolution de notre constitution il
suggéré de modifier l'article 36 de
notre texte fondamental pour y faire
figurer l'état de siège ainsi que l'état
d'urgence et sa proposition renvoyait
une loi organique soin de préciser
des conditions d'utilisation de ces
régimes je considère que cette
orientation doit être reprise il s'agit
de pouvoir disposer d'un outil approprié
pour fonder a prise de mesures
exceptionnelles pour une certaine durée
sans recourir à l'état d'urgence et sans
compromettre l'exercice des libertés
publiques
cette révision de la constitution doit
s'accompagner d'autres mesures
il en va de la déchéance de nationalité
de nationalité la déchéance de
nationalité ne doit pas avoir pour
résultat de rendre quelqu'un apatrides
mais nous devons pouvoir déchoir de sa
nationalité française
un individu condamné pour une atteinte
aux intérêts fondamentaux de la nation
ou un acte terroriste
même s'il est né français je dis bien
même s'il est né français dès lors
qu'ils bénéficient d'une autre
nationalité
la constitution c'est la charte commune
c'est le contrat qui unit tous les
citoyens d'un même pays
dès lors que la constitution et le pacte
collectif indispensable pour vivre
ensemble il est légitime que la
constitution comporte les réponses pour
lutter contre ceux qui voudraient y
porter atteinte
de la même manière qu'eux sont voués à
la dissolution des associations ou les
groupements de fait qui provoque la
haine ou incitent à la commission
d'actes terroristes
mesdames messieurs les parlementaires je
vous demande de réfléchir à la décision
que j'ai prise et je demande au premier
ministre de préparer cette révision avec
vous afin qu'elle puisse être adoptée
dans les meilleurs délais
et
en
les doigts et
et
en vélo
à
bah oui
ouais
vachon
plus à
sur collecte afin que je puisse être
accompagné le président arrêtez